[Music]
this is star talk I'm your host Neil
degrass Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist and I'm here with my
co-host Chuck Nice Chuck it baby what's
happening Neil all right yeah you know
what we're going to talk about today um
I don't okay commercial space flight oh
really yeah we haven't we haven't
tackled that subject in a while so what
we want to do is bring in some expertise
absolutely help I know a little bit
about it but I'm not like in it right I
can talk about it like
stratospherically right because in the
last decade there's been a major
advances in commercial Aerospace yeah
yeah you got Elon Musk you got uh Sir
Richard Branson you got the bald dude
that's one day going to rule the entire
world yes billions billions of dollars
hey you know I hadn't thought about it
he could be a bond villain that's right
are you kidding me there's never been a
better candidate for a real life Bond
villain than Jeff basos
okay like you just see him you know just
they're going to name him like scorpion
that's going to be his new name you know
it's me
scorpion so guess who we found we found
the one and only yes Lauren Lions wow
Lauren Lions welcome to Star talk thank
you so I was looking at your profile oh
my God so so in college you majored in
aerospace engineering is that right I
did you did and then then you went on to
study was it business and government or
something on top of that I did but you
work for Firefly Aerospace yes uh and
you were in the engineering leadership
at Blue origin mhm and the blue origin
is is Jeff bosos and a senior engineer
and Technical program manager at SpaceX
nice ticking all the boxes that's all
the boxes man all the boxes and while at
SpaceX you worked on starlink Wow which
we people complain about starlink do we
blame you we'll get find out in a minute
definitely we're going to totally find
out if that's your fault the alpha
rocket uh blue moon and the Falcon 9 wow
we we would just we just we would just
the booster Memorial the booster
Memorial oh the nine don't call
it a memorial that's what it's called oh
my God what a morbid name no Monument
Monument mon big difference good point
it was the first one we ever landed yeah
no she said not the first one ever flown
first one
ever landed softly hence Memorial that's
why you got you got to pour a little
beer out of your old L 800 for the
boosters that aren't here yeah if you
has all the ones that gave their Liv all
the ones that came before true it's
right there it's out in the open La Sky
you can see it from Air from the
airplane when you're coming into LAX you
look out the left side of the plane and
there you see it every single time wow
it's pretty cool well it's interesting
that she said that because that means
the wind patterns over LAX hardly ever
change you just look out the left side
like cuz if wi has change then you'd be
looking out the right side right so what
a statement about the how the regularity
of air patterns wow what did you do for
the Falcon you worked on the Falcon 9 I
worked in so it was like the very first
job I had at SpaceX I came in being what
they call a mission manager and you're
basically the systems engineer that's
responsible for saying hey we're going
to make sure that the customer satellite
that the payload gets integrated onto
the rocket safely and so that's
everything from managing all of the sort
of integrated analysis that has to
happen like Thermon analysis mechanical
structures analysis um down to actually
being at the launch site so were all
these launched from Cape canaval so no
uh Vandenburg Air Force Base just a
couple hours north of north of La that's
where I had my very first launch
campaign my very first mission um but
most of at the time most of this is back
in 2015 most of the launches were going
out of the cape and we were launching
out of Vandy maybe like once a yeary get
that first name oh yeah Vandy yes okay
we're not we we're not at that level I
know I don't not nearly Aeros Spacey
enough to call it VY okay we're with you
though Vandy you're VY VY yes yes um but
you know just to be clear there's a I
think of vanderberg I think of Air Force
Base yes is there a a civil portion of
that launch no so you are on the now
it's the space force but uh you were on
the base so you have to get like go
through all the military checks you got
the little badge for the not just some
side no platform that you can launch
Absol you are on yes as opposed to the
cap there's the Kennedy Space Center
side and then there's the Cape Canaveral
Air Force well space force station side
um at least it was the last time I was
doing launches and so I don't know if
that's changed but it used to be able to
go you can go to the Kennedy side or you
can go to the the Air Force side but at
Vandy it's a working Bas they have you
know space force do you know the area
code of Cape con uh I do not what is it
321 you didn't know that I think I
should know that like I totally should
know that should have know that dial in
those numbers oh my cool Man 3 two one I
got to tell you I want to say it's corny
but it's not actually very cool it's
very cool very cool it's very cool so
tell me exactly okay so the integration
of the payload to the rocket service
that you're providing correct all right
and so you have to check for safety or
that it's not going to jiggle the thing
out of operation all of those things so
so basically if someone says I want to
launch a satellite and I'm talking like
not those sort of missions where SpaceX
throws like you know 50 small satellites
but if someone comes with like a big
satellite and they've paid you know
billion dollars or100 million doar or
$50 million for this thing they show up
I don't want you messing that up you
can't mess it up right right so they
hire people like me to be that kind of
goet so some of your compensation comes
from the company that wants to launch
the satellite because they need your
Assurance uh no not necessarily sorry
let me be more clear what what happens
is I I was working for SpaceX and you
can't just have this customer show up
and they like I want to talk to all the
engineers and I want to know if am I
going to vibrate off the you know the
attachment and you know right they need
to know what what could harm their
precious payload based on the parameters
of the launch correct and so what they
do is they give you a set of
requirements they say this is the
trajectory I want to fly this these are
the loads that the satellite can
withstand a series of things across the
entire of spectrum please affirm for me
is there no greater love of of an
engineer than a set of requirements no
no actually let me be real so I come
from like the commercial space world
where requirements are obnoxious I was
going to say Oh Oh I thought so for you
for you for you it's the no green M&M's
in the green room that's yeah it's it's
it's aain I thought the engineer loves
being inventive with the constraints
placed upon them from the outside is
that not true so you know there there a
way to overdo itology I think in the
arrow not when you're the person who has
to actually make the mission
work when you're when you're just
somebody who's given the challenge right
and you just want to design something
then it's great because who cares like I
want a Stairway to nowhere and I don't
want to see any supports underneath of
it oh okay that sounds awesome right but
you tell a carpenter that he's like f
you man the hell is your problem right
so so what are things so it's vibration
acceleration surely what else Acoustics
and so you want to make sure that while
the satellite's in there and as you're
ascending with that rocket you're not
going to like introduce all this
acoustic noise shake roll exactly
because you could do harm so many things
environmental controls temperature um
air flow you want to make sure you don't
get condensation that you don't reach
dupoint inside of that fairing so now
these specifications change for every
single flight not necessarily so the way
well just a quick Point your dupoint is
more likely to be hit in Florida where
the humidity is high exactly so you're
constant remind what D point is it is
the uh temperature at which like water
vapor will condense and become liquid in
the atmosphere and so imagine you it's a
temperature that you drop to yes yes
because above that everything is happily
exct happily in in it's happily uh
making you miserable gases
G and it's not going to deposit so the
reason it becomes an issue like water in
of itself in some cases if you have
something that's not hermetically sealed
um that obviously becomes a problem in
cases where things are sensitive to that
right but Ina even when you're not
talking about electronics and things
like that where imagine you're in a
situation or in this room and it's not
super clean and there's like particles
in the air there are there's like
particles all in this we don't have to
imagine that cuz it's happening right
now it's everywhere I'm telling you and
so now if you reach dupoint that water
catches those particles so I worked on
let me give you a specific example I
worked the first launch that I signed up
to work on which is the reason I went to
SpaceX was to launch test the transiting
exoplanet survey salite um amazing
that's one of my people my figured you
love T Test we all love test test was
basically the follow on to Kepler the
transiting exoplanet these are planets
orbiting other stars that pass in front
of the whole star and dim the star and
so yeah it's adding to our catalog we're
we're Rising through 6,000 exop planets
right
now okay so you you're you're in the
club you're oh that's why I went I was
like I want to launch this I was like I
don't have the skills to contribute to
this Miss but I want to like launch my
people I love it cool though okay so
Tess had fouras you ever before you do
you ever like when we discover exop
planet do you ever just take your phone
and go I did that uh not anymore cuz it
happens so often yeah I know it's
happening every day planed every couple
of days it's cheap and boring now right
okay yeah you're just like let's yeah
just keep it up keep it up test let's
keep finding more and more and more yeah
so test so yeah so Tess Tess has four
cameras that they had four cameras that
in the fairing well it's s inside of the
fairing which is the Shroud over the the
payload they're just looking straight up
and there were no covers on them or
anything and so imagine if you reach
dupoint and you got all of that
particulate then settled down on those
in the on those four upward facing
cameras AOL one of the people that I
worked with uh she used to say she used
to tell the engineers who were like in
charge of contamination control she goes
if you mess this up we won't find any
aliens no aliens so you got to make sure
that you and it became this that's a
perfect plot for a movie for someone who
doesn't want to find aliens make sure it
does con keep it nice and dirty nice and
dirty so I'd forgotten can we get a lens
wipe over here guys oh and they were
uncleanable on top of that too cuz they
were so delicate you couldn't clean them
oh your lenses are typically coated with
anti-reflex ction that but that might
have different reasons but in general
the lens is not just glass there's stuff
on top of it as well and you start
wiping it you start wiping off the the
protective coating damn yeah that is INS
it's not protective coating it's it's it
prevents reflections of light because at
every surface you cross there's light
that reflects back right and then part
some goes through and there's a way to
cancel out those Reflections so that you
have a perfectly transparent glass and
so yeah you don't want to you don't want
to rub that off but I had not
appreciated until you said it moments
ago that when you hit dupoint it's not
just water condensing right the water's
grabbing whatever any particulate that's
in and then and then when that water
evaporates that stuff often times get
left behind just sitting there so let me
ask you because I did she finish finish
test okay so tell so what happened with
what did you do for test so I was the
role was called Mission integration
engineer and I was you know when NASA
came to us and they're just like here's
this crazy contamination control
requirement which is one of the
strictest we've ever seen it was my job
to work with our Engineers inhouse to
make sure that we were taking the
precautions in terms of environmental
control and the fairing environmental
control in the clean room in order to
make that to meet those requ test made
Tess was a a Goddard and MIT uh
collaboration um with um I think Goddard
made who made the bus the bus was
orbital yes gter space wi Center on the
science side also made the cameras and
uh the spacecraft bus itself was made by
orbital ATK at the time now north of
grumm so Tess Tess is flying high right
now so congrat thank you for your
service on that it when when you're
dealing with all of these highly
sensitive apparatus do you is there an
insurance policy attached to this
because let's let's get to that that's
right so so the risk factors that's a
whole thing launch failures does someone
get blamed for that or do absolutely or
do you say this is an occasion where we
will learn a great deal you kind of have
to do that last one anyway like it
always is a learning because if you knew
it you wouldn't have ended up in that
situation and so there's a ton of
learning that happens in it um but you
know I worked multiple launch failure
investigations I worked them at SpaceX
and I led the failure investigation for
Firefly for our first uh rocket which
exploded in spectacular Fashion on our
very first launch which is like not
unheard of for the first launch to not
be successful right but they when
Rockets fail they don't just sort of
fall over no they're basically
spacular it's generally spectacular yeah
it's you reminded that when you're
taking off it's a highly controlled bomb
right you're in control of the bomb if
you're not in control the bomb it's it's
an explosion exactly how do you get data
from that if everything if the evidence
has been blowed up so interestingly it's
rarely completely gone even in the case
of the the mission it was uh God f920 I
believe it was the 20th Falcon 9 flight
um where we lost Dragon over the water
we still even though the everything
exploded and ended up in the ocean we
still were able to collect some data um
some physical evidence but just to get
the parts right so the the the Falcon is
the booster correct and the dragon is
space the spacecraft on top okay so all
these names they're just band out good
point yeah I just want to make sure that
we we got the yeah let's exp right okay
yeah because I'm old school the Saturn
five
rocket on top of that was the Command
Module right so and that had a name yes
right so this is the corresponding good
point yes argument here I guess okay so
I interrupted go on no no that was a
good clarification um so there's the
physical evidence side but I will speak
to early flights like early missions um
for when you first build a vehicle you
want to collect as much data as you
possibly can so I was you know speaking
on the Firefly incident by the way
they've had 100% Mission success for the
next missions that they had they killed
it but that first one that's a good
thing and a good thing I was like
crushed there any like positive words
that don't like mean like
destroy crushed it I killed it killed it
it was a success knocked it out of the
park so violent I'm an old man on the
porch you know these young what
good okay uh so um so what you do is you
end up and it's not even just the early
missions definitely on the early
missions but even later on what you do
is you instrument the heck out of those
Vehicles like you've got thermal couples
you've got accelerometers you've got
every kind of instrumentation think just
picking up dat and there are those who
you know there are a lot of folks for
example there's a lot of launch Vehicles
out there by the way and other
spacecraft that don't really have a lot
of like cameras on their vehicles at
SpaceX we had them everywhere but a lot
of people didn't have them because they
believe that that data is more useful um
I personally of am of the opinion that
both are incredibly useful and the data
I probably prefer data over video
frankly um but if you've got video like
it's tremendously helpful even just for
correlating to an event that happens
during uh an accident or anomaly MH um
so yeah you even if you don't have all
the physical evidence mhm code word Eed
up yeah something anomalous yes an
anomalous yes anomalous condition you
know the word it's mishab a mishap yes
this is the word the FAA uses mishap a m
how well what a what a lovely
euphemism I believe we've had a terrible
mishap I'm going to need a new pair of
underwear yes well you know if if it's a
really bad thing that happens uh there's
like levels of bad with these
investigations if it's really bad it's
an accident wow yeah so a mishap okay
I've done mishap in mishap Happ just
dust dust it under the rug keep going
right it's like you know you just yeah
it's these are the ones the FAA will
allow the compan follow your entire life
but a mishap a mishap you can get rid of
okay before we go to our our fan base
set of questions we're going to turn
this to a little bit of a cosmic
Aquarius just want to get from you um I
just want to help our audience and
US understand the fundamental
differences
between the government putting things
into space into orbit and private
Enterprise yeah do you do you have a
different tolerance for error than the
government
does it's a complex question because it
depends on how error or failure is
defined okay so100 million yes down a
tube for whatever reason the government
can say all right we're we're going to
try that not to have that happen again
but an investor doesn't lose money
gotcha uh yeah and in some cases $100
million is all you got and if you're in
a private Enterprise and you have a
failure like that uh you could be done
you could be completely done well that's
the end of your it's the end of your
company your compan is gone that's your
Runway because you don't have another
$100 million in the bank that you could
go or you can't go to Congress and
apologize okay so there could have been
10 other launch companies that came and
went for just those reasons there were
a lot of people had tried this stuff and
you know Elon likes to say all the time
he got really close like that last
Falcon one launch that company would
have gone SpaceX would have gone
bankrupt had that one not been
successful the one that worked the one
that worked that's on display right uh
Falcon 1 oh Falcon f one yeah um and so
he tells that story all the time I mean
it was down to the so this this makes
sense because the people who are the
leaders in the industry are all
billionaires
depends on how you Define leader but
some there are there are
some there are some that are
billionaires and there are many many
more who are not and the billionaires
are the ones who get all the attention
attention they get all the attention
they're the ones people love to talk
about that's fair but there's a lot of
people executing in the corners okay
crushing it okay right in the corners
and people don't know their names people
don't know what's going on and and and I
think like that's kind of one of the
things that always kind of like
frustrates me a little bit with a
billionaire Space Race narrative by the
way like I'm not one of these people
who's going to be like this is all false
we should not criticize this I don't
fall into that camp like I think there's
some like valid you're safe here you're
in a safe space me and and I I'm not
going to be those people that just
defends anybody just because I'm in the
space um but I do think that one of the
things that kind of frustrates me about
that narrative is it it kind of ignores
the fact let's just take you know blue
origin for example I believe there's
like 11,000 people there at this point
right either seven or 11 I don't know
some lot of people lot of people and
whatever you know criticism you want to
hurl at Jeff like he is but this much of
that company that company is made out of
you know 11,000 hardworking people who
care very deeply about the work that
they're doing and and let's be honest
just because you're the pockets of an
organization doesn't mean that you are
the impetus for his success correct
because I'm sorry the guy may be and
PayPal was wonderful and all oh you're
talking about Elon I'm sorry both of
them all three of them yeah but I I defy
any of them to sit down and tell me how
to put something into space can they
really do that seriously at least one of
them can like give you a little bit of a
run for your money I've been pleasantly
surprised by like how much Elon can like
go head-to-head on a lot of things yeah
he's he studies pretty hard and he's
pretty like read up on stuff and he's
very at least was in the past I'm not
there now so I don't know how Hands-On
he is anymore but he was quite Hands-On
um and so after what he did with Twitter
I'm I'm I'm a little
scared but yeah it's like to your point
like that's a different that's social
engineering that's different different
different it's to fun it's it's these
these like these hardworking Engineers
who are there you know pulling the all
nighters I've always felt that when
people say oh Neil Armstrong was the
first person on the moon and I'd say was
NE AR plus 10,000 scientist Engineers I
say that all the time thank you for that
thank you thank you plus a little known
fact the mission patch for Apollo 11 did
not contain the names of the
astronauts didn't no it did not it's
just the eagle coming for touchdown on
the moon I love that that that there was
a nice touch I love that the Yankees
they don't put the names on the back of
the jerseys no they didn't right right
well they were the first to ever have
numbers on their jerseys right so that
was just the batting sequence exactly
all right let's go to what see what our
fan base has to say all right let's do
it this is uh Cameron Bellamy and
Cameron says greetings from Baltimore to
Neil Chuck and Lauren what are a few of
the current and biggest unsolved
challenges in the field of human
commercial space
travel that's a good
question uh I think the biggest one
single biggest one is expensive it's
incredibly the whole point of SpaceX
trying to drop the price so they haven't
dropped it enough is what you're saying
not remotely so um so like it it depends
on you know if you want to talk about
you know making it accessible to not
just governments or billionaires right
um we got a ways to go and do you
quantify ways
so I will say okay so so Elon put some
people in orbit yes all right that was
how much per person so I believe NASA
pays 88 million a seat or something like
that $100 million well that's less than
a lot of other options they the other
two options that they have okay um I
believe so and and I I a billionaire
that's okay but most people aren't that
so what price do we have to get that
down to and will it ever get there or is
it going to ASM toote at some level that
no one is ever going to reach and it's
going to end the whole the whole effort
I think we'll get there and the way that
cost comes down is not just through
reusing boosters I mean like that helps
for sure but it's still not where it
needs to be um
Falcon 9 can only do so much in its
current I mean it's it it does what it
does well this is why they're developing
star help to get to orbit and then it
comes back correct yes but so this is
why they have Starship right you got to
push those boundaries and so what
Starship enables is to drastically
reduce that cost uh of for launch and so
because of how many people so the cost
per person the cost per person the cost
per launch the cost of materials the
cost of fuel like everything it's
they're dropping those costs and it it's
such a large vehicle as well that it can
carry much more mass to orbit So
currently the way you think about mass
for every sort of kilogram that you put
in space like that's what we talk about
cost of launch you think about it is 2.2
pounds thank you thank you for that I
used to sell drugs so I'm very much
aware very much aware okay good good you
sell kilograms of
drugs high roller roller hey we don't we
don't do the small stuff like yeah wow
so you have numbers there for cost okay
good so the Saturn 5 it cost
$54,000 per kilogram launch to low earth
orbit wow okay the space shuttle was
$65,000 even more per kilogram and that
was supposed to bring cost down I know
it did not work out did not work out
there's your government working for you
yeah so then you've got the Falcon 9
which is currently at if you're going to
get a dedicated Falcon 9 just to
yourself uh
$2,600 per kilogram so it's 26,000
2600 that's huge okay that's a factor of
of 20 that's insane fact of 20 from the
Saturn 5 it's amazing okay all right so
so all right so that brings in many more
customers yes who would have orbital
things they want to do yes okay exactly
and so like right now if you wanted to
launch uh Chuck how how many kilograms
do you weigh let me see what cost to
throw throw your ass in orbit let me see
put my fat behind in orbit What would CA
well are humans considered payload uh
yes okay yes so do you tell people to
lose weight before they go into orbit I
what they they tend to be pretty fit
these astronauts so low contact they
tend to be pretty fit when we start
really thinking about human space light
and not just kind of circling the earth
cuz it's like great cool boldly going
where g go further right every I mean I
don't know the exact numbers on this but
you got to keep these people alive they
need food they need water they need air
they don't got that in space you have to
keep the people alive exactly yeah and
it's expensive and so and and it and it
requires a lot of mass so if you're
going to carry Mass Beyond you Mass
Beyond you so the environmental control
systems and life support systems there's
a lot of effort so getting back to that
question there's a lot of effort that's
going into figuring out how to have
closed loop systems right and so that
you don't have to have all these excess
consumable there code for drinking your
own pee of precisely of course it and
growing plants us the fertilizer from
yourself to like grow the next ones we
saw that mov po
potatoes on this um so you know figuring
out that question as well and regardless
like you're going to still need to bring
consumables with you so you're going to
it's going to require mass and you need
a big rocket but you also need that
rocket to not be crazy expensive right
and so that's that sort of balance that
that kind of needs to happen to make
that work um and then the other thing
that I think a matter of time I think
it's a matter of time I really if we
showed the Falcon 9 to the Wright
brothers they they would have an
aneurysm right and die on the spot on
the spot right right so how far away is
this I think we are given what we've
accomplished thus far yeah so I mean
what is it like later on this decade you
know SpaceX is supposed to be launching
our astronauts to the uh to the moon so
that's going to happen uh they've
actually sold the first Starship
launched to a guy named Jared isaacman
and Jared is supposed to launch himself
and a crew of three others at least
three others I believe with him for what
just to go they just
going Jared don't come back that's what
I'm saying well he's also doing like a
bunch of like research and stuff science
and things too right thought it was a
joy ride wait what fundamentally
different from the dawn of Aviation were
the only people who flew in an airplane
were very wealthy it's so true and they
did it for just the thrill of and some
of them died yeah some of them did right
right yeah yeah I think there's
even nobody was
mad no nobody was mad when no in early
Aviation when those planes went down and
everybody on the ground knew that there
was nothing but rich
people who were going for a joy ride
they were just like that seemed like a
problem taking care of itself that was
like around the time of the depression
too it
was politically interesting around that
time so yeah I think um
those folks that are able to to pay for
these experiences were just not quite at
a point yet and was like oh the space
economy is so big it's doing great and
it's just like is it because these
markets don't actually exist yet there
isn't a market that exists that allows
this sort of real economy to come up and
so similar to when you think about the
Arts and engineering and technical
things back in the 1600s and even before
then who used to pay for that
it rich people and so this is the same
should have any unique discomfort with
this fact this is how it is this is how
it works it how and how and thank God
that there are people who have this
hunger to do this crazy stuff or
capitalism there's that oralism as it
was in with the med Medi yeah wa so so
give me I want you to be quantitative
so how many years from now 10 years 20
years where where a family can save up
and and and instead of we Disney World
are we going to go to space get your ask
I think it's 20 years maybe 15 but
probably 20 that's really close that's
very and I don't mean to Mars I mean
like go and do a little circle around
there's also company there's two
companies there's uh worldview and space
perspective and they're doing these
balloon uh flights and those are
supposed to be coming on in the next
couple years balloon launches don't have
the same appeal they do not but it's way
more chill you're not on a bomb you just
kind of like slowly go up I remember o
floating away on his balloon that was
just not as exciting as a rocket launch
I'm sorry I'm sorry you wouldn't do it
though no what on a balloon would you do
it uh I don't know I
mean yeah I don't know probably I
probably would it can it's not like a
rocket Rockets blow up exactly now what
if you could get the orbital perspective
like you could get that sort of overview
effect without being on a bomb yeah it's
not a it's not a bad idea it takes a
little longer balloon yeah what do you
think no it goes to a school room Globe
it goes up the height of the thickness
of a dime so I I'm not counting that as
an overview that's okay okay no you
can't see National borders but neither
can you from an airplane okay so I'm not
me and
balloon I did the math on that right got
it okay CH give me another one all right
here we go this is Alex we luxuriously
answered that question we did but who
cares um this is Alexander Harvey
and he says hello there Dr Tyson and
Chuck this is Alex from Denver Colorado
reporting in what are the biggest
limitations on
constructing uh now listen cuz he's
going out there a floating human colony
in space and how might we overcome those
limitations my man is like I want a
colony living in space I wouldn't use
the word colony
um
well colony is different from colonize
that's true it's true it's still like
it's too subtle it still carries some
baggage it's a word with baggage so
there are two kinds of colonies we can
think of one is like on a surface of
some place right like the Moon that
sounded like a free floating col he
wants he wants he wants an O'Neal
cylinder O'Neal cylinder so Jord O'neal
He had Fantastical ideas about our
future uh living in space with farms and
so so you said what's a Jord cylinder or
the oal cylinder yeah I mean I'm not an
expert on these things but like the sort
of self-contained environments that are
just in space where people are living
and thriving and working and there's
grass and water and there's closed
ecosystem if you saw the movie elium but
hopefully without the classism just like
a little exactly that would be great
yeah be rotating so you
have have gravity gra yeah it's so cool
okay so how far we we from that we're
very very very very very very far from
that um like okay so to the question of
what do we need to do to get there so
first uh in the last few years there
have been a number of new companies that
have spun up in order to build
commercial space stations we currently
don't have any of those and so let's
start there like let's start so the car
space stations are National correct
Chinese and and the ISS okay and NASA
has already said you know we'd like to
partner with commercial industry to do
this so they have done some sort of
small Awards to some companies to do
some early design work on that and so
there are companies out there that are
trying to do this but you know what
these things cost billions of dollars a
year just to operate and the logistics
money ass play this is this is a it's
it's crazy and and then just like and
one of the biggest chunks of that cost
is just in the process of getting things
and people to in from it so launch Cost
needs to come down right Additionally
you start thinking about it and you're
like really are we G to just built these
massive structures with stuff from Earth
that's silly so then we have to start
thinking how can we actually get
materials from the Moon from asteroids
how can we assemble materials print them
print them bring the raw material
material right and assemble things in
space so there's this whole sort of
field that's coming out so cheaper to
move something from an asteroid to your
space platform not yet then from Earth
to the platform the idea will be once we
figure out the whole asteroid mining
ISS um then that starts to more sense
for these structures it cost nothing to
launch from an asteroid got hardly any
gravity right and it's got a lot of raw
materials a lot of raw materials so just
I'll get it from an asteroid forget
Earth yes yes wow okay so that would
unlock like inspace manufacturing using
materials from inace that's trying to do
that uh there's a few yeah which one are
you thinking the one that wanted to make
money mining asteroids there's yeah
there's uh company called astrof Forge
what think there's one called Carmen
plus keep going there's uh a couple that
no longer exist
maybe lovely people but they space
resources that was a compy there's
planetary resources and then there was
Deep Space Industries okay these were
two that founded by wonderful humans
they were dreamers they were just a
little early I think and and now that
Resurgence is coming back and yeah all
right so again we're in the decades not
centuries we are in the decades
uh well in the case of O'Neal cylinders
I don't know man that's one where there
there's a lot that needs to happen to
make that well you know what's going to
help that along is that we're going to
need them you know see that's the
problem the way we're treating the
planet you know we're going to actually
need to go someplace for a little while
to allow Earth to recover or we can stop
messing it up oh we get I mean listen
would would you go to one and live there
and behind one of these O'Neal cylinders
depends on how nice it is if it was a
two-way ticket let's say it's uh let's
say it's the Ritz Carlton of O'Neal
cylinders oh dang and what is it
orbiting oh my God damn she's getting
all articul she still requirement are we
in the Saturn system like where are we
wouldn't that be cool be beautiful would
be beautiful like that scene in
interstellar I cry whenever I see it
when he gets there and there's like the
rings of sat rings of sat God it's so
beautiful oh my God so I'm getting all
like about getting yes okay
move on let's here we go this time for
just a couple more this is Alex Pon and
uh he says hello Chuck and hello Neil
hello Lauren this is Alex Pon Chuck it's
pronounced and then he spells Alex
fanatically because Chuck Chuck has
issue problems pronouncing people's
names not that not that bad my problems
aren't that bad and not with Alex right
yeah with Alex like Alex Alex Alex yes
yes yeah okay anyway he says uh hey
calling here from uh Bethesda Maryland
thank you for taking my question Lauren
what new and exciting technology are you
most excited about that we don't know
about
oh is it in propulsion is it in Material
Science I am really excited for and it's
going to you already know about it
though people already know about it just
is is re fully reusable Rockets I'm
talking the first stage the second stage
and that they can fly once a day stem to
stern up and back up and back like the
way we take planes exactly like when you
get off your plane your plane isn't
sitting there waiting for you to come
back it goes on to another destination
or it goes back to where it came from
taking more people back there yeah but
Chuck I can fly a plane to a destination
and it can refuel at that destination so
if you're going to have a rocket that's
empty of its fuel when it gets to where
it's going you need a filling station on
orbit so that's another thing that gets
me excited is exactly that so the way
Starship works as an example they can
launch all that Mass to orbit but if
they're going to get to the moon they
need to refuel on the way there so
refueling technology I think enables us
to go deeper and deeper into the solar
system so you need cargo ships carrying
fuel to Depot yes you need fuel Depot
absolutely or which sounds weird but
somebody have to do that when cars were
invented ex they're still doing it and
they're still doing it I want to drive
there yeah well there's no gas St well
somebody says I'm going to put a gas
station so you will drive itay there's a
company called orbit faab their tagline
is gas stations in space and that's
entirely what they're trying to do all
they're trying to do whole it's a thing
industry Community yes north of Grumman
is working on this there's a company
called astroscale that's working on this
SpaceX there's so many companies it's a
key part of the architecture if you
really want to like go further I'm glad
you all are doing that this is pretty
exciting actually while the rest of us
are fighting over the meaning of words
on our social media postings right
there's some people still thinking about
a future no it's it's incredible and
then like to even push that even further
because I'm a big fan like I am obsessed
with like my favorite thing in the solar
system is Europa like obsessed cannot
wait for Europa Clipper um but I would
love Clipper that's not going to dig is
it's just going to orbit no it's just an
Orbiter it's going to do flyby so it's
Orting why can't you just not wait until
the one that digs uh ask NASA that
question and it's come money okay I
don't think it I think it's on paper but
it's nothing funded to do that correct
yeah they were like kind of working on a
study and and it just didn't quite make
it to the next Lev is the one that got
icy out surf surface that you have ocean
underneath Global
liquidus but I thought there's a uh uh
plan to fly through some of the plumes
of Enceladus there and with europ Europa
Clipper is going to fly through they we
believe that there are plumes on Europa
as well not the 101 crazy things that
you get out of Enceladus but uh Europa
we believe there are plumes and so my
understanding is Clipper is going to go
through and kind of taste The Taste the
plumes and look for Organics some
chemical analysis of that very nice
Cosmic Taste of rainbow Cosmic taste yes
exactly so so that's something we can
all imagine okay we want to know
something secret that nobody knows that
you know cuz you're in the biz that when
you when you reveal it we say
whoa for me I'm I'm just so interested
in the going further question we have to
be able to go further and right now we
can't and there the we is people people
we have robots at the edge of the solar
system yeah and like I don't what are
you going to do if somebody is like you
know 30 40 50 years it's nuts right so
actually uh there I'm a part of the X
prize's Brain Trust for the space sector
that we've got where we think of X
prises that are space related and one of
the finalists this year so ex prises are
you put up money for an audacious goal
and then
everybody puts in their money to do it
to hope to get the prize right and the
total amount of money everyone spends is
more than the prize money that someone
wins and so you get the benefit of this
creativity to decide this I am I am for
the space orace space sector right yeah
because exerprise there's biology right
Healthcare education all these things
and and so one of the the finalists this
year was this idea it was called sleep
like a teenager and this biologist
brought it forward and she's a medical
doctor and she and she said hey you know
we need to learn from the animals about
hibernation and hibernation doesn't
necessarily mean going into like the
little pod and you know like being
knocked out for you know 100 years um
like in the movies like in the movies
hibernation could be simply just
lowering your metabolic rate to the
point where you don't consume as many
resources that's what animal hibernation
is sometimes bears are like actually
awake in there they're just like moving
a little slower right and so like how
can you lower a human's metabolic rate
enough such that they to that point
about Mass require fewer consumables
what if they were only working you know
maybe 3 to 6 hours during the day and
they slept the rest of the time like you
could actually that could actually work
and so uh so maybe that answers this
question of you know it's not something
a lot of people are talking about but
it's something a feature that would be
folded into this this exercise so this
is for long duration missions for long
duration space you know my reply to that
question is MH invent a
wormhole then all take minutes oh my god
did you just guess the secret technology
that no was she was not going to talk
about
yes if he had that secret believe me we
would not be sitting
here he'd be trying to share it with the
world and I'd be like no sir we got to
make this
money I must share this with the world
Chuck will revolutionize travel a last
fast question about the Falon n cuz we
were visiting the the one out on on the
street corner I noticed nine nine rocket
motor nozzles at the bottom is that why
it's called Falcon 9 that is why it's
called Falcon 9 so did Falcon 1 only
have one nozzle it did have one nozzle
okay look at that just just verifying
I'm waiting for Falcon 50 I'm also like
not convinced that it was called Falcon
one because it had one it was probably
just because it was the first
one kind of makes sense just checking
that so what's in store for you what
what are your I I understand you're
moving to Paris uh what's that about
yeah I want you here a I come back and
forth all the time no no
here we need you are you working are you
working with like the French Space
Program over there no I'm just doing my
thing so I've been Consulting with us
companies and and so just doing it from
so they come to you to get what from you
so my expertise took that pandemic
remote working thing too
serious from anywhere so you have it
shall be these multiple companies on
your resume now yes with this various
experience and now you now you have
turned that into an independent
operation yes and you're CEO of this
operation I am and what's it called it's
called V do Labs V do Labs V do for
acceleration
second it's very nerd see look at you
but you got it there cuz some people
just look at me like Virginia Department
of Transportation like that's not what
that means
so um the rate of change of your
position
right it's called your speed okay okay
right and your velocity the rate of
change of your velocity is called your
acceleration okay Isaac Newton developed
a system of nomenclature and notation to
represent the rate of change of your
position relative to time and the rate
of change of your velocity relative to
time and it's called dot okay dot yes
gotcha okay remember correct that's
correct okay so V Dot is basically the
first derivative of your velocity which
is your acceleration right and and you
only really go in places if you can
accelerate right just to be clear yes
and that's what we do so geeky we have
and know oh it's 100% intended to be and
that's so completely geeky and it was it
was entirely Isaac Newton he invented
the dot the dot notation for for
derivatives and the is v. what labs v.
Labs but yeah so that's exactly what we
do is we help startups go fast help them
do really hard things accelate startups
help accelerate their Technical and
operational capacity that's because it's
not just materials or just the
traditional what we think of is
engineering I'm impressed to learn that
Engineering in modern times modern Deca
recent decades is making stuff work
systems of systems yes oh I nerd out on
that so much it's
no it is it's so good it's so good it's
my favorite thing hey get a room sorry
it's like guys like oo the systems of
the system systems of
systems I could play it on a loop let me
tell you about the
system we hit the spot right there yes
you did uh no it's it's you know people
look at some of these like incredibly so
I study High performing organizations
and I'm in the process of writing a book
on this looking at what are the trends
and things that we can see between
organizations that build hardware and
what are this what is the algorithm
around that and I think a lot of
companies they they're constantly in
search for it they're always looking for
this and it's not simply like how good
are your processes and how good your
engineers are it's the way in which you
structure and build the organization to
remove as many barriers from execution
as you can so are you like are you two
space companies what McKenzie is to sort
of ordinary corporations where the
corporation doesn't have the internal
expertise to how to run their business
better and so they go to a consulting
company that says fire these people hire
those people and accelerate your
progress is that what you are for space
companies in some ways and what we like
to do is get like very much embedded
with the organization because my team
and the folks that work with me are
people who have been boots on the ground
they're not you know career Consultants
who've only kind of looked at it from
the top they just got out of Harvard
Business School nothing against that
love HBS love HBS uh but what it it's
people who were in those roles but just
to be clear the the rowing team for
Harvard Business School at the tip of
their ores is a dollar sign oh wow okay
just they don't is this real yes it is
real oh my yeah that's their that's
their you know others just have like
colors for the flag of their school or
they a dollar sign I mean it's not
inaccurate like in terms of what happen
go faster
the Say Hey I love scoping off a dollar
sign uh but anyhow yeah I mean if the
the I like your reference to boots on
the ground that's an important reality
that brings a certain level of trust yes
and and to be able to see a problem and
to go oh my god I've lived through this
I feel like so many times I work with
these companies I go oh there was that
one time let me tell you we did this and
here's what we did and here's how we got
through it CU I feel like there's so
much tribal knowledge in this space and
it pains me this work is so important
that we're doing in order to accelerate
Humanity's future in space I don't think
we can afford to be treating everything
like you know ah don't look at it don't
look at it it's m you all go off the
cliff together exactly and you knew
something that they didn't they needed
to know so they didn't fail and just
like repeating the same mistakes over
and over again and frankly if like your
success hinges on you know someone else
just making a mistake I don't know if
that's like true and so how my goal and
my passion with this industry is to be
like how can I sort of bridge those gaps
how can I remove those barriers the
things that those tribal knowledge
blocks and help others just Leap Frog
the stupid stuff so so in order for you
to be really effective typically you're
working with a smaller company yes
because small companies are more Nimble
than big companies they are they and
they're they tend to be like more hungry
for change yeah oh yeah the change
Factor yes because big companies they
don't want to change yeah and even if
they do it's like it's hard it's really
hard but I think also what you see is
there's now existence proof it's
difficult I've been in those companies
and but you know that now there's
existence proof you can look at a SpaceX
tell Chuck what an existence proof is
like it's there like we don't have to
like H imagine imagine a world where
like no like there's a company called
space but it's okay that no no no no
it's it's you don't have to figure out
whether it is true or can happen if
there's an example of it having already
happened so in math in math is it's
actually an existence proof oh it's it
comes from math okay an existence proof
here's the thing you trying to prove
that this can happen I already know
already did it's right there it's not I
did it it's just it's there all right
well how could it be there if you didn't
do it because someone else
did and so and you asked me about you
asked me about Europe and like France
right
what is so interesting is Europe is
about 10 to 15 years behind the US in
terms of like commercial space and so
they have this opportunity now that they
have their's existence proof they're
like wow it's been done what are we
going to do now bring an American over
to show them how to do not not so much
but just you know bring some of those
Lessons Learned and what is it it's
going to look different there because
it's an inherently different ecosystem
but it is fascinating because it is ripe
it's brand new it's fresh so you going
where the opportunities are there's a
lot of opportunity there wow a lot of
opportunity wow that soundss really
exciting we have to report back good for
you I shall we got to come back and and
find out what we got see how your
predictions are going right decadal
decadal predictions for the the O'Neal
cylinder yes all right this has been
another episode of Star talk with a
little bit of cosmic queries sprinkled
in yeah on the future of commercial
space with Lauren Lions uh and like I
said Lauren we take our invitation
seriously you could check back in with
us you want to know what what changes
you were uh wreaking upon the world yes
uh at at Chuck and if France starts to
beat us in the Space Race we are going
to blame
you all one team we are all one team
there it is there it is transatlantic
cooperation there you go all right Chuck
always good to have you man always a
pleasure all right this has been Star
Talk Neil degrass Tyson here your
personal Master physicist as always keep
looking
up
[Music]